So now, since we're talking about the incremental and iterative
nature of the Rational Unified Process, let's have a quiz on
the benefits of iterative approaches. So I'd like for you to tell
me what are these benefits. Is one benefit the fact that
iterative approaches keep developers busy or maybe that they give developers
early feedback, that they allow for doing the same thing over
and over in an iterative way. Maybe they also minimize the
risk of developing the wrong system. Can they be used to
improve planning, or is it the benefit
that they accommodate evolving requirements. Also, in this
case, I would like for you to check all the answers that you think are correct.